I didn't think Lance owed anybody uh he
didn't do anything to
me you know what he did for me he raised
$500 million for cancer research that's
what that lie did that was great all
right and everybody had the bands on
remember the bands sure right on last
that that blocked out the sun
right no it wasn't to block out theis
cancer
yeah now the whole thing was annoying
and I hated how Oprah was interviewing
him and acting like she was dumfounded
that this guy would do this like she's
been in Show Business for 35 years and
she can't like wrap her head around some
guy doing whatever it takes to get to
the next level didn't she for the first
5 years have like midgets who wanted to
bang their mailman's boyfriend and and
she didn't want to do it she didn't want
to do it but she didn't have the power
to say no so she wrote it out and then
when she could make a good decision she
did a show but she stood on the heads of
those little people for 5 years until
she got and then she's sitting there
across from this guy like like so how
could you you know exactly what he's
doing are you with your girlfriend
living in La yes I am I'm technically
married but I'm married how like I want
to be married yeah which is I don't sign
that Behind the Music contract where you
know everything works out until it
doesn't work out yeah no you see sugar
sh one of the greatest boxers of all
time he's losing his championship belt
in a
divorce that's losing yeah it's like
you're trying to break a man why does
she want those right break they go with
their
shoes you
know no and I love how when you get a
divorce all of a sudden it costs like 50
Grand a month to give a kid Froot
Loops he I'm telling you there is an
epidemic of Gold Digging [__] in this
country
and it is just not being addressed on
any level what are you talking level
what do you mean what am I talking about
every guy out there is just getting
nobody's safe oh my God nobody's safe
football players
actorss nobody and they never get called
horse Arnold schwarz's maid is still
called the maid in the story she knew
his wife on a first name basis hooked up
with this dude in their bed and is still
called the maid why did she bang them
why because of that 1987 flat top He's
Still rocking right you don't think it's
because of that Kindergarten Cop money
he's got laying around
the I'm not and listen I'm not
condoning what the man did but you know
there just needs to be guys need to be
educated there's nothing out there to
help a guy handle becoming rich and
famous for that that that platoon of
[__] that's going to come over the
hill like like Braveheart faces P skirt
on
just yes there's nothing out
there no it's like guys never learn how
to keep themselves in check Society does
it for you yeah just women aren't going
to bang you cuz you drive the forklift
at Home Depot right despite the fact
that you want to bang all of them
they're not going to do it so you didn't
keep yourself in check the forklift job
did right then all of a sudden you hit a
lot the lottery you know yeah and then
you can just give into all of that like
I don't I'm so sick of all these trolls
coming on TV judging these Great
Men these Great Men all these guys
anytime one of these guys gets caught
for screwing around these guys come
waddling out of their cubicles with
their JS absolutely reprehensible
Behavior like they have any idea what
it's like to be tempted at that level
you know yeah as you walk over to your
Ford Focus are you really beating these
women off of you all those people who
judge Tiger Woods how many people he
golf when was the last time you walked
off the 18th hole and there was a
busload of Scandinavian women waiting to
hump your brains out and you're like
sorry
ladies you
know no means no that's another one no
means no it's like no it doesn't all
right look look no means no no that
means no all right but no stop it what
are you doing oh my God you're being so
bad stop it no yeah that's not a [__]
no that means I want to do it but I'm
afraid you're going to judge me so I'm
just going to make it look like it was
your idea so you don't figure out that
I've already performed this act with 40
other [__] people
right but then then you go to court and
you get a bad read and there's some guy
reading ah you're honor she said no stop
it what are you doing you're being so
bad yeah and you're just sitting there
like she didn't [__] say it like that
she didn't say it like
that I got to admit the only thing that
freaks me out about Los Angeles is uh is
all the plastic surgery I don't get it
why do people get plastic surgery you
know why can't you just admit it's
over you know you had your time stop
trying to look [__] in your
50s it's weird dude their faces yanked
back looking all shiny
right not to mention they haven't even
figured it
out you know why would you get a
facelift can't you look at other face
lifts and realize they haven't worked
all the bugs out
yet right that's what you want to look
like like you just lost a fight 3 days
ago don't be a hero let somebody else go
in there take the [__] beach you you
lay back wait it out they're just lying
to people I know looks great looks great
put a little ice on it we'll see you in
a couple weeks all right take it easy
Jesus Christ what the [__] happened we
followed every step did we miss
something oh hey hey hey oh here's your
keys here's your keys there you go there
you go almost didn't recognize you you
look so young all right take it
easy she gone she's gone all right shred
everything shred
it no you're
nuts you wait it out let him figure it
out then you [__] go in don't be a
goddamn hero you know look at hair plugs
hair plugs don't look half bad now saw
this guy the other night on TV he's like
oh God I wish I did this 10 years ago
it's like no you
don't 10 years ago when they was
stapling ant legs to the top of people's
heads remember that your eyes would
water looking at their hairline like is
that is that son in I see
pinear least to put you in like a
headlock hold still use like a nail gun
hold still guys would tap out after a
row and a half [__] it I don't give a
[__] you wish you got hair plugs 10
years ago do you wish you got polio 60
years
ago what else is on your wish list
sir no you don't [__] with your
face okay I understand lipos suction
they screw that up you can put on a
shirt
right there's no shirt for your
face who do they think they're fooling
but they're stupid you know and then you
lie to yourself I'm just going to do I'm
just going to do this just GNA just
gonna just G to have this done no you're
not you're not what you you're just
going to wax the fender on your car then
that's it the rest of it looks all
shitty well maybe I just do the hood and
maybe I'll do the back that's how it
happens then you look like one of those
real housewives face all twisted
up [__] idiots do I look yeah they're
idiots do I look like I'm in my 20s no
you look weird you look [__] weird
you still look like you're in your 50s I
just can't guess what year anymore
because I've never seen that year I've
never seen that shiny [__] look it's
almost like you discovered a new age
between 52 and 50
yeah people there's nothing wrong with
being 52 and looking 52 all right you're
52 you didn't get [__] yeah what would
you rather be 52 and look 52 or be 52
and look like a 28-year old
lizard right that's your options at this
point transgender athletes I don't
[__] understand understand that you
know I understand it if you know you
want to switch around I don't give a
[__] but I'm a sports
fan that's a really New Concept to me
that you can be a dude right ranked 80th
in the [__] world you have your dick
cut off you put on a sports bra and now
you're the number one tennis player in
the world just coming out there with
your man's
shoulders that doesn't seem fair I might
be wrong I might just be an old guy I
have no idea
but I'm hearing rumors like some of them
are getting into that MMA you can't have
that
[__] my nuts that is a [__] dude
beating the [__] out of a
woman Jesus Christ he might as well hit
her with his discarded dick like a
flashlight hold still oh it's grounded
her grounded pound is incredible so I
think about the population all the times
you've been telling on my specials I'm
always talking about it I think I got
the plan cuz I know no no no wait till
you hear the plan first cuz a lot of
people are going to
die before you start hooting and
hollering everybody thinks they're going
to [__] make it right this is how you
do it this is how I would do it okay
first of all you got to become a
dictator okay because it's too late to
try to be like well hey man maybe just
have a couple it's too [__] late
someone's got to have the balls to take
out the
sickle and start chopping some heads so
here's my idea I become dictator when
you become dictator obviously you got to
murder everybody in power right from the
head all the way down to their goldfish
you got to kill everyone in the family
so they don't come back for their
revenge like in Godfather 2 or every
karate movie you've ever seen right you
got to do it the way the Russians did it
where you don't find the skulls for a
100 [__] years that's the way you do
it then you take control of the media I
keep all you guys media blacked out you
don't know what's going on unless I want
you to know it right big pictures of me
me you got to sing songs about me if
there's no passion in it a black van
pulls up and you're never seen from
again all right figure three to six
months of that everybody gets on the
same page and that's when I'd start
thinning it out this is how I would do
it I would just start randomly sinking
cruise
ships just hear me out it's the way to
go it's the way to
go you get 2500 to 3,000 people a whack
and I think it's a really good mixx of
people to get rid
of you know think about the kinds of
people that take a
cruise these aren't forward thinkers
these aren't Seekers they're not pivotal
to our
survival you ever hear somebody coming
back from a cruise it's one of the worst
stories you're ever going to hear cuz
they don't do [__] they don't want to
travel to another country interact with
the new culture try to figure out the
train system of the money all they want
to do is just sit on a [__] boat just
drinking that's all they want to do
right worst story you'll ever hear hey
how was your cruise oh it was great I
was [__] laying there there was a DJ
over here on the one in the two wer wer
thing right and then they had this
chocolate fountain was like a fountain
but it was chocolate and you stuck the
toothpick in the food and you stuck it
in the
chocolate stuck it in your mouth and
then you be like I want another drink
and they bring it all you drink it it
dribbles down and it gathers in your
navor you punch yourself you get in your
mouth then every day around noon we line
up for lunch what's for lunch we don't
know we don't make decisions whatever
they give us I like all inclusive you
just have to think once can I write that
number on this piece of paper all right
tell me where to
go I'm telling you if you guys could
just get past the humanity of what I am
suggesting if you could just get past it
and maybe lose a couple of friends here
or
there I'm telling you you wouldn't miss
them you wouldn't you know when you'd
miss them when you when you went to when
you went to a baseball game and there
wasn't those hundred people in the upper
deck trying to get the wave going
right you wouldn't have people getting
mad cuz someone's sitting down during a
song like that's offensive to me even
though I don't know the issue right
Nashville little pulled back on that one
little pulled
back it's about police brutality has
nothing to do with you and your
beautiful white world and mine right
just let it go I don't give a [__] if
you watched every episode of M's Navy
this is still not about you it's not a
military
issue I'm telling you you wouldn't
[__] miss them and this is the deal
all right I wouldn't just give the order
to start sinking these cruise ships and
then retire to my Chambers with my
Mistresses my [__] right just banging
away wearing the whole uniform the whole
dictator uniform everything except for
the pants right compression socks with
sock gers just banging away my unearned
Metals just clanging off my chest the
big thing is to see how long I could
[__] and keep the Hat on like yeah yeah
yeah
yeah N I can't do that that breeds
resentment amongst your men you got to
lead them into battle and I would I
would I'd have my own sub all right I'd
have my own sub and I would hunt these
cruise ships on a moonlit summer
night that's right on a moonlit summer
night when sound carries you know you
know those summer nights when your
neighbor's talking about you doesn't
think he can hear them you're sitting on
your porch going like oh yeah is that
how it
is so that's how it is right one of
those
nights and I'd be a sport about it I'd
surface before I did it I'm armed
they're not it's only fair right they
see me I give them a little wink a
little nod I'd have a little Red Baron
class all right get the [__] out of here
right but if you didn't see me it'd be
game on every moonlit summer night every
summer I'd go out to harvest right that
would be the deal I would just
surface
on listen for the music
[Music]
yeah would fire
one
dude look at my arm in this tank
[Music]
top and then you cruise over you strafe
all the
survivors we bringing it
out that would be it 2500 to 3,000 less
people and he wants the greatest thing
no it's all underwater all the evidence
is gone all the evidence is gone every
mass murderer throughout time is [__]
up they did it on land you're going to
get caught where you going to put all of
that right you do it out to sea it all
goes under you know nobody know I don't
know what I have no idea right no
evidence no evidence maybe maybe like a
flip-flop
right like an Ed Hardy shirt just
floating
by I'm controlling the media nobody
knows about it right and as I sank the
ships I would be building exact replicas
at the same time right so I'd be
eliminating people while creating jobs
you guys have no [__] idea what's
going on only you just realize like wow
man the traffic's easing up I'm getting
into third gear at 5:00 at night this is
crazy this is amaz I don't know what's
going on with this bill guys all right
you know another buddy of mine got a job
building ships can you [__] believe
that that industry is just blowing up
and it's crazy dude I want to get a job
down there they paying great you know
make a little extra money then you who
knows maybe you and me take a cruise we
have a good time right get out
there now that's how it work that's how
my ethnic cleansing would
work it wouldn't be based on race or
religion it' just be based on people
dumb enough to think that taking a
cruise is actually
traveling technically you're traveling
you know but what are you seeing just a
bunch look at the water oh my God you
can tell that's the Atlantic Ocean that
definitely does not look like the
Pacific
Ocean they really have to come to this
people they really have to come to
it I really hope all of you run into all
those black people that you love so much
here in Camden I really hope that
happens I hope there's a line of all of
you guys get [__] carjacked and they
take out their big black dicks and they
just shove them right in your [__]
mouths each and every one of you and
somehow they just keep repeatingly
coming right in your [__]
eyeballs until it builds up so much that
your eyes they [__] crust over you
can't see [__] and somehow there's
another dick in there for you to suck 10
minutes
left look at you this is what you
want this is what you want a
[__] bunch of [__]
losers [__] Rocky is your hero the
whole pride of your city is built around
a [__] guy who doesn't even exist you
got [__] Joe Frasier is from there
but he's black so you can't [__] deal
with them so you make a [__] statue
for some three-foot [__] Italian you
stupid Philly cheese eating [__]
jackasses I hope that cheese melt your
[__] faces off all of you
collectively suck a [__]
dick I want to kiss
you I want to kiss you you told me that
we should go our separate ways but now
you're for a to stay oh it's not right
now one of my
fantasies is I want to drive by like a
woman's rally and just say the most
sexist [__] I can think of just to watch
them lose their minds you know just
drive by real slow like yeah I want get
back in the kitchen where you
belong just a look in the rearview
mirror watching him flipping out in the
road spinning around like Leatherface at
the end of Texas Chainsaw Massacre
[Applause]
like yeah no it's a very uh I don't know
times are changing I guess I don't
know yeah Michelle Obama's doing an
arena
tour that's another thing going on I'm
going to say that again Michelle
Obama is doing an arena tour she's not
playing comedy clubs she's doing
Arenas when did first lady start acting
like they got
elected you
know dude being a first lady that's not
a [__] job just standing there
smiling and
waving right look how quiet is it in
here why is it so [__] quiet you
think that's a
job it's not a [__] job dude if you
really think it's a job just look at him
right look at Obama when that guy got
elected he looked like he was about 41
years old when he left office that guy
looked like he was about 73
right look at Michelle she looks younger
now than she did when that dude got
elected what has she done for the last 8
years
yeah other than lay in a giant vat of
Illuminati level lotion just sit there
floating a couple hours a shape shifter
comes in and dumps another bucket
on she pops her head up hey Bam Bam tell
Stevie Wonder to come down and play some
songs
tonight man I found out she's doing a
tour cuz uh she's doing a book tour yeah
she wrote a book she wrote a book about
not having a
[Music]
job I gotta read that [__]
book chapter one how to know if a dick
tastes
presidential how to weed your
way how to weed your way through all
that local representative [__] and get
to the big swinging dick in the
room
I'll tell you right now say what you
want about Republican presidents but
they got their first ladies in
line they
do dude George W was President for eight
years eight years I don't even know his
wife's
name was it Abigail or some [__] Maggie
no
clue Donald Trump's wife stands behind
him like a giant Mir cat
like Bill Clinton was President his wife
never shut up I want to do Health
Care he [__] around on her so much
he's like all right whatever just do
it but I'm telling you right now I'm
going to I'm going to check out that
[__] tour I got to see what that's
all about you know who opens who opens
on that [__] tour
was it Oprah Winfrey's husband you
know does he [__] come out and talk
about what it's like to Walker
dogs I do it for 20 minutes a day the
caucus Spaniel's probably the most
fussiest and I got to bring him
around look I'm sure that there's some
uh feminists in the crowd right now not
appreciating this joke feeling triggered
feeling like they need to [__] put
out a hashtag or something [__] and be
brave and speak
out you know what you're full of
[Music]
[__] you
are
all all those feminists are full of [__]
cuz I'm going to tell you right now
someday someday there's going to be
there's going to be the first woman
president all right which means which
mean you don't even know what you don't
even know what her [__] platform is
and you automatically cheered
it's good to save
genitalia [__] I'm telling you
they're not smart people feminists they
they're not as smart as they're coming
off I'm telling you
someday there's going to be by the way
it's is going to be my last show ever by
the time this [__] thing comes
out someday there's going to be the
first female president which means there
going to be the first male first lady
right
and you wait you [__] wait the first
time that dude opens his mouth about
some political [__] you watch all these
feminists throwing me you shut the [__]
up you shut the [__] up it is her time
now it is her time she was elected not
you go pick out some plates [__] you
are the first
lady he's going to get treated like Tom
Arnold when he was with Roseanne
Secret Service name will be like
appendix or doesn't
matter not worthy of protecting just
enter the Oval Office not worthy of
protecting I love about sports is it's a
great way to tap out from the news and
just you know watch a game and get away
from it now it's like all these causes
are getting like attached to it like I
was watching the World Series and I'm in
the middle of watching the World Series
and out of nowhere they have this moment
stand up to cancer I'm watching a ball
game and all of a and everybody stands
up with holding up a sign of somebody
that they either know that's dying of
cancer or died of it in the middle of
the game it's just like what are you
doing trying to watch a game here you
know no there's a time and a place look
I know
somebody I know somebody that has died
of cancer I would never go to the movies
with you and in the middle of it hit
pause and be like oh by the way Conan I
know this
guy he died of cancer was horrific I
could have lifted him up off the sheet
with two fingers it was horrible hey
enjoy oh by the way I got molested when
I was nine enjoy like I dat to this girl
one time she was like really into like
women's
issues so we used to always have these
dumbass arguments like one time she came
up to me she goes okay explain this to
me B why does a guy make more an hour to
do the exact same job huh H H I go I'll
tell you why because in the unlikely
event that we're both on a Titanic and
it starts to sink for some [__] up
reason you get to leave with the kids
and I have to stay
hey that's why I get the dollar Mar
out no think about it if there's a house
fire it's always women and children
first I got to stand there with like the
back of my shirt on fire going Let's go
people let's go let's
go so that's how I look at it no it's a
dollar an hour sear
charge that if something [__] up
happens either I can't leave or I I got
to like get in the way of it to give you
a head start like rabbit dog run honey
One Mississippi two
Mississippi you hear a bump in the night
I got to go check it out like yes he
does have a
knife anytime there's a hostage
situation who do they negotiate for
first well at least let the women and
children
go what about
me bullets hurt me too why the [__] do I
got to stay in the
vault
no that's my point man where are all the
feminists in those situations you know
what I mean you can't find them they are
no feminists in a house fire that's a
that's a guarantee you could take the
most hardcore feminist some chick right
in your face like he's show T of a [__]
little short little haircut the whole
nine yards right second those Flames
break out she's going to twist those
little hairs into pigtails no I'm just a
girl I want to go play jump
rope and leave you standing in a burning
house like you're not
flammable you know but I'm not I'm not a
dick
though I'm not I'm not saying I think a
woman should make a dollar less an hour
to do the same job all I'm saying is
you're going to make what I make when
the boat sinks you better be standing
right there next to me listen to that
guy Play The Cello then you get the
corner office
you get all the benefits or whatever